Joining me today as a professor of
English at the University of Ottawa and
author,
a self declared anti feminist and a
campaigner for the right to dissent.
Janice,
be mango.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
I want to thank you very much,
Dave.
It's nice to have you here.
We were looped in by this Jordan
Peterson Fella.
Apparently everyone knows this guy now.
So before we do anything else,
I thought it would be interesting since
he looped us in together.
What do you make of the Jordan Peterson
phenomenon?
Well,
um,
uh,
to say the very least,
I think what Jordan proves is that there
is an incredible hunger out there
amongst young people maybe amongst young
men in particular,
but um,
obviously amongst women as well for,
um,
for,
for something that's really genuine and
hard hitting and real in terms of
discussing what matters in the world
today.
Uh,
something that we aren't getting in our
public conversations at all.
And uh,
and Jordan obviously offers that and uh,
and all of the attempts to discredit him
and to claim that he represents
something really dark and nefarious.
Um,
it clearly isn't working.
And turning people off.
It ain't going to stop though.
No,
no,
no.
It's just ramping up,
I think.
Yeah.
What is going on in Canada that there
seems to be a burst of Canadian
professors from,
from Jordan to you and God says,
and plenty of others,
uh,
feel free to name drop some others that
should be on my radar.
There seems to be a real pushback from
Canadian professors,
at least a small select group of them
against this sort of group think and pro
photo diversity and whatever you want to
call this whole move.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm actually,
I think it's unfortunately still a
relatively small group.
I would say.
I think there needs to be a lot more in
the way of pushback.
The thing that really struck me about
Jordan Peterson situation when he first
sort of burst onto the scene with his
declaration that he would not,
um,
you know,
he,
he would not engage in forced to speech,
um,
that,
that not a single professor at the
University of Toronto would come forward
even to say.
I may not necessarily agree with what
he's saying,
but I support his right to say it,
and that's one of the largest
universities,
if not the largest university in Canada
and probably the most prestigious one.
And the fact that not a single professor
felt that he or she could stand with
Jordan in that moment.
That was astounding to me.
And so,
um,
yeah,
there are a few.
And Gad sad is a wonderful example.
I have a close friend at,
um,
acadia university who was actually just
fired this year,
Rick Mehta,
who was inspired by Jordan,
he,
he was someone who had been thinking for
years a lot of the things that Jordan
has talked about in terms of the group
think in academia,
the whole range of subjects that you can
even talk about,
well,
that you can't talk about from a variety
of positions that you have to take one
position on a.
and so he finally started speaking out.
Before this,
he was an award winning teacher and the
year he started speaking out,
he had so many complaints and he's now
actually been fired.
A tenured professor.
This is an astounding thing.
So,
um,
so unfortunately I would say that what's
happening in Canada is that a few people
are speaking out and a lot of people are
speaking privately,
I'm saying,
you know,
I really support what you're talking
about and I really wish I could do it as
well,
but it's way too dangerous for me to do
so.
And the case of Professor Mehta at
Acadia proves that indeed people have
reason to be very fearful.
Yeah.
You know,
in the case of Professor Metta,
it's so interesting to me that one of
the ways I get guests is that suddenly
someone does something often at a
university and then it starts bubbling
and there's some stories,
right?
And then I started hearing about it on
twitter and then it bubbles up enough
and then they usually end up right in
that seat where you are right there.
And I suspect he'll probably be adhere
to.
And in a weird way,
all of you guys are just defending the
ability to think about these issues.
The positions that most of you are
taking off and wouldn't have been
considered radical 20 years.
Absolutely not,
no,
they wouldn't have been.
In fact,
I mean in,
in Professor Metta is case.
It seems to me he's such an excellent
example of the fact that this is not
about even an,
an individual saying offensive things
because
what were the supposedly defensive
totally.
I mean,
and he didn't take these as positions,
you know,
he,
I think would,
would identify himself as a classic
liberal.
He's not particularly conservative,
but he,
he wanted to talk about the full range
of issues he objected to his
universities indigenization program,
which I think maybe was the most
controversial of the subjects.
And this is,
I think this is probably now the top hot
button issue at Canadian universities.
Um,
it's the,
um,
the move to replace European based
knowledge as exclusionary and inadequate
and subjective and to replace it in some
cases with indigenous knowledge.
Uh,
and even in something called indigenous
science,
which many scientists would say is
actually not.
I mean there is only there science that
is all there is.
Um,
and so indigenous science has to do
with,
um,
indigenous ways of knowing elders'
knowledge.
What some might say is superstition or
magical beliefs,
sort of anecdotal kinds of observations
and you know,
there is an attempt on the part of
universities in some ways a lot of one
to bring in indigenous peoples who've
been excluded from the university
experience for many years for a variety
of reasons.
But,
um,
the idea that indigenous knowledge is
not to be questioned that it has a value
equal to supposedly European science is
a really incredibly worrisome and
strange idea.
And so he objected to that and he raised
a whole bunch of other questions,
not even saying that he wanted to,
that he was necessarily taking a
position on them,
but merely saying that,
you know,
he,
he said that identity politics is
divisive and causes resentment.
Who would've thought,
believe it?
I never heard that before.
Yeah,
he,
he talked about,
um,
you know,
the,
the psychological science about
differences in,
in preference and interest and
intellectual ability between men and
women.
Um,
he,
what else did he talked about the wage
gap and said that there was a lot of
evidence to suggest that it was based on
preferences and choices that people made
rather than bias against women and their
whole bunch of.
And he really was just trying to do what
exactly as you said professors once
we're supposed to do and that's now no
longer possible in,
in the university classroom.
And I think a lot of students probably
liked him.
I mean he got these teaching awards and
he had a lot of support even up until
the point that he was fired.
But because I,
a condray of very angry students and
also very angry colleagues and it is
often professors who are persecuting
other professors.
They claimed the complained about him
and said that he was harassing them.
So let's put the student part aside for
a second because we're going to get to
that a little bit,
but the colleague,
the fact that so much of this is being
driven by other professors.
I mean we saw this with Bret Weinstein
at evergreen state.
Jordan and many of my other friends who
are professors now tell me,
they often get support privately from
professors but not publicly,
which is the most enraging God tells me
about this all the time.
But what do you make of professors that
are,
that are leading this charge against
inquiry?
Well,
they're true believers.
I think many of them and,
well,
some are true believers.
They,
they,
um,
they see themselves as part of a
revolution that's absolutely necessary.
They believe that our society is one of
entrenched inequality and structural
violence against,
against racial minorities,
against indigenous peoples,
against trans people.
And you know,
the,
all the,
the uh,
uh,
the claims and uh,
and so they,
they see that any attempt to argue or
against their positions or to simply
call for more open discussion is a way
of reasserting of very unjust.
They would say,
you know,
deathly status quo.
And then a lot of people I think are not
true believers but are just going along
for career reasons or because it's
easier to go along.
They just want to do their research and
they can only do it in peace if they say
all the correct,
you know,
platitudes.
Um,
so I mean,
what happened was that I think
gradually,
um,
the idea of the university was destroyed
it whenever it started,
how it happened.
I mean,
it seems to have started sometimes in
the late sixties.
Allan Bloom,
I'm sure you've read the closing of the
American mind,
you know,
he,
his claim is that professors lost faith
in the idea of the university as a sort
of separate space where you simply
thought about things you didn't get
involved.
And I,
he has a wonderful line.
I remember something about how socrates
felt that it was more important to think
about justice and to,
to really learn what justice is rather
than try to implement whatever partial
version of it,
you know,
as roiling the public consciousness of
the day.
And um,
and so that was what the university had
meant at its best,
I think.
And this is a case of where the
university original mission of being a
place to find truth and giving people
the opportunity to think about these
issues,
debate these issues,
etc.
Has taken a complete one 80 because now
it seems to be the breeding ground for
the opposite of those ideas.
It is a breeding ground for sure.
I mean,
it's,
it's wHere,
um,
all of the indoctrination takes place.
And then of course the students who are
indoctrinated go out into all the major
spheres of our society.
They,
they,
they go to law school where they,
they read critical legal theory that
tells them that they're there is,
there's nothing unbiased or objective
about the legal system that we have in
north America that it needs to be
completely remade.
Um,
they,
they become journalists and they go to
journalism school where they learn the
same thing and they're told that a
journalist should be somebody who
attempts to improve and change society,
make it better rather than just report
the,
you know,
what's,
what's happening.
They become teachers,
they,
they go into the education faculties
where they're also being radicalized and
you know,
and so it's not surprising that this is
where we're at now.
One of the things that fascinates me
about this,
every time I hear another professor come
in and talk about it or I just see
another breaking story about it or
another monument taken down or whatever
it is,
the ratio of history,
is that what you said before about the,
the indigenous sciences.
It's like they don't want you to just
say,
okay,
maybe we can have an extra course in
this and teach it hopefully with the
same academic rigor as you would teach a
european scientists or what's known as
you said,
as science.
We could have a,
a parallel course if you want to take
that as well,
but they actually,
they want to replace history in that.
That seems to me to be the most
dangerous part of this.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well and it.
But it's not surprising if you believe
that the system that we have now is,
you know,
kills people.
It's always.
The rhetoric is really,
really extreme.
It's like,
you know,
what you're saying is,
is violence to me and my family,
what you're saying,
you know,
causes people to die.
So if you really believe that in some
way,
then you can't just bring in,
you can't just have add ons of other
courses.
It is a,
this is not a referral for the witches.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's this and it's not a reform movement
even where you could get to a point
where you would say,
okay,
we've made,
you know,
certain structural changes to satisfy
these various concerns.
It is a radical revolutionary movement
that,
you know,
everything has to be smashed and rebuilt
and,
and yeah.
And,
and I think um,
there's a,
a very naive confidence on the part of
many professors that,
that they know better than generations
and generations of people who came
before and then they will be able to
build jerusalem.
I somehow somehow doubted.
all right.
But,
so let's back up a little bit and again,
get to your involvement at all of this.
So a self declared antI feminists,
the defender of descent.
I'm a big fan of descent.
So just tell me a little bit about your
academic background and what sort of
brought you to believe some of the
things that you believe now.
Yeah.
Um,
well,
you know,
I started off as I think a pretty well
to go back further.
I started off as a,
as just a,
you know,
someone who loved literature.
I was a nerd.
I love to read and that was all I know
from the time I was very young.
I wanted to be a university professor.
I want to teach literature.
So then I got into graduate school and I
was radicalized there,
I would say,
um,
like everyone,
you know,
and,
um,
and that experience was really important
to me and that I realized how incredibly
pleasurable it is to be a radical.
Describe that a little bit,
that feeling because it's,
you know,
it's a,
it's a very addictive and maybe it is
even a kind of addiction.
I'm sure that there are all sorts of
chemical changes that go on in your
brain when you're feeling this.
It's a combination of sort of euphoric
rage and I'm self righteous indignation
and um,
and,
and uh,
yeah,
righteous outrage and uh,
so yeah,
I,
you know,
I did all the things.
I marched in,
take back the night marches and I worked
at a women's shelter and um,
and then suddenly then I started to see
that my purpose in a becoming a
university professor would be to
radicalize other students and to show
them what I had come to understand.
And um,
yeah,
and it's,
it's a,
it's a very heady experience and I've
thought for years and years like when I
came off it because I think partly
because of my background,
my parents,
um,
are lower middle class and my dad died
last year.
But,
um,
somehow the,
that outrage,
it just didn't fit with the values that
they'd given me and it,
it,
I couldn't hold on to the,
the conviction.
How long did it last for you?
it lasted while I was a graduate
student.
Really?
So like from about 1991 to 94 or
something around there.
And then it started to fade off because
I just started.
Do you remember moments?
Was there a seminal moment?
There wasn't one moment,
I wouldn't say,
but there,
there were just,
there were a number of moments where I,
I just,
I couldn't hold on to the sense of
conviction.
I,
I can't think of a specific moment until
I'm like,
by the time I started teaching full
time,
I started teaching full time in 1999.
And at that point I would've said that I
was,
um,
I probably would've said I was still a
feminist,
but I,
I would have seen myself as more of a
moderate feminist and,
and um,
and I wouldn't,
that wouldn't have been my primary self
identification.
I would have said I was an animal lover
or something else like that.
And then,
but nine slash 11 was really my,
that was my moment.
And it was because at the university
that I was teaching at at the time,
university of saskatchewan,
I'll never forget that morning,
um,
I was already at work.
The secretary said that know planes had
flown into the towers and I was
horrified.
And,
and,
but I noticed that the mood at the
university and in my department in
particular,
it was one of like barely contained sort
of haunting pleasure.
I couldn't believe it.
And,
or at least,
I mean maybe that's maybe not everybody
felt that that could have been just my,
um,
my sense of it,
but certainly a kind of satisfaction.
And in fact one of my friends came into
the mail room and said,
well,
they've got what they deserved.
This is like,
you know,
within an hour of the news.
Another said that she was going to teach
about it that day.
And this was like really early on in the
term.
So she hadn't even really started.
I think this was be like our first week
or maybe the first part of the second
week.
But anyway.
And she was going to teach about the
event and she was going to talk about
how,
how this would be used by reaction,
how this would likely be used by
reactionary forces in the United States.
And how it would be very interesting to
watch over the next few days who they
would blame and how they would begin to
manipulate.
I thought,
wow.
Like it hasn't.
I mean,
you know,
it,
she never even thought that maybe
there'll be students in the class who
would be really upset.
I might even,
you know,
somebody who knew somebody or it was
just the,
the lack of human empathy and the,
the hatred,
the satisfied hatred.
That was really my moment that turned me
off completely.
Um,
from the,
everything to do with the,
the left,
the progressivism,
the anti american ism,
the anti western culture,
everything.
Then the other thing that was happening
at the same time,
um,
role in the year before too,
was that,
um,
my department was doing a fair bit of
hiring and we were doing what we called
equity hiring,
affirmative action hiring and um,
we were very,
very keen to hire more women and to
hire,
um,
members of visible minorities and
indigenous people.
And I,
I jusT,
you know,
and there,
there was,
you weren't allowed to obviously object
in any way and nobody did.
Everyone,
a set,
maybe occasionally privately,
a bit,
a bit of demoro,
but um,
but basically everyone was publicly very
enthusiastic and it just struck me as
the most unjust,
ridiculous thing.
I'm basically like no men,
no white men were,
were even considered for any of the
positions that were offered.
And I,
I,
I couldn't see how that was a good thing
in any way at all.
And it just,
it seemed to me outraging and the all
and you know,
we would get hundreds of applications
for some of the positions and all of
these men who had done all these amazing
things being just being put aside and
women who had done far,
far less being considered and brought in
for interview.
And always the idea was that,
you know,
this was equity hiring,
which meant that if two candidates were
equally qualified and you know,
we would choose the woman.
But of course,
as soon as you're looking to hire for
political reason,
you're not considering the true
qualities of the candidates at all.
So in,
in a situation like this,
if we,
if you had two candidates that had the
exact same criteria and you had a
department that was,
say 90 percent male in that case,
what would your position be?
This.
I know what you're saying.
I never get to that place where it's
exactly what the proposition a.
Yeah,
no,
there are.
There are never two candidates who are
exactly the same and I honestly could
never see a situation where it would be
so urgent that you would hire on the
basis of a,
you know,
an identity category.
And I can't believe that.
I mean,
the arguments for,
um,
changing the,
you know,
the demographic mix of workplaces or
whatever,
I can see them applying in very narrow
circumstances.
For instance,
in primary school I would say yeah,
it's probably a good idea that children
have a mix of men and women and as
teachers and maybe even an ethnic mix if
it's an ethnically mixed school,
I could see that as important.
And in fact,
that doesn't happen because,
you know,
most,
um,
primary schools are taught almost
entirely by,
by women.
Uh,
so little boys who might not have a dad
at home are not even getting a chance to
have a male role model,
male role model at primary school.
So that would be a place where I could
maybe see the case for it,
but at a university I just,
I really can't see the necessity I do.
I don't believe that any promising young
person is actually going to be turned
off a subject because they don't see
somebody who looks exactly like them
reflected in the professoriate.
And if they do,
then what a deeply profound a
disturbance has already happened in the
education system.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean I just,
I mean,
I don't believe that our system is,
is so exclusionary and you know,
that,
I mean we hear this so much about how
now,
especially women in stem and also I
guess um,
um,
racial minorities.
but,
but I hear more about women need,
you know,
they,
they just can't go into astronomy
because supposedly there aren't enough
female astronomers.
A friend of mine who actually left
Australia,
he was working as an astrophysicist in
Australia.
He left there and went to China because
he realized that there was no future for
him at all.
Like,
no,
he couldn't possibly get a tenure track
position because they were so set on
hiring women or other identity
categories.
And um,
he always sends me things.
And recently he sent me something,
a phd student was being brought in to
talk to.
Um,
I think his old department,
she said,
I'm so glad I'm not there anymore.
Uh,
and,
and she was going to be talking about
how,
uh,
you know,
there are,
there are not enough women represented
in astronomy because even like the laws
are named after,
they're all named after men.
So there's like newton's law,
you know,
law.
Yeah.
And that was the idea that some of these
laws should actually be named after
somebody else,
even though they're named after the men
because the men,
obviously we're the ones that discovered
the laws,
you know,
I mean,
it's just,
it's ludicrous to make their own
discoveries exactly for themselves
regardless.
But they couldn't because they're just
so,
you know,
so beaten down by the oppressive
maleness of the discipline.
And it's just,
it isn't true,
it's not true.
I mean,
I could see if,
if,
you know,
male professors were standing up telling
these female students up,
you're never going to,
you know,
you don't have that right brain for it
or whatever.
Well that would be temporary,
but nobody is doing that.
Nobody's doing that,
you know,
professors are delighted to have anyone
who's promising and capable male or
female or whatever color their skin is.
It just isn't the case that there are
all these,
you know,
systemic barriers to participation.
So,
so when you had these two experiences,
so,
so nine slash 11 and then the hiring
process,
what I find often,
and I think it sort of happened to me is
once you have your little wake up about
what this sort of uneNding monster on
the left is,
everything else collApses pretty
quickly.
So how does,
how did that collapse,
if the rest of the collapse was pretty
quick,
how did that lead you to where now
you're so outspoken about feminism and a
series of other issues?
Yeah,
well it just,
it did.
Everything else didn't collapsed pretty
quickly.
And,
um,
and,
and what I became especially upset about
was,
was the,
um,
what I came to see as the really
negative environment for,
for young men at,
at university because I,
I,
I began thinking about what it must feel
like to sit there.
They,
after day after day,
hearing about how all the good things in
the world are the contribution of women
and all of the bad things or the
contribution of men and how,
what young men have to do today is
basically just take a step back,
step away from the power as professor
susanna walters said in that Washington
post piece,
uh,
why can't we hate men?
You know,
that's what you have to do as a man.
You have to bear the weight of centuries
of male privilege and oppressive
behavior.
And you just have to step back.
Don't run for office,
don't do anything.
I mean,
you know,
as if.
I mean,
it's unbelievable.
But yeah,
basically,
yeah,
and know,
be abject,
apologize for your soul called privilege
and let your sisters come forward and
make the world a better place.
And that is,
I mean,
that it's so crUde and so ridiculous,
but I don't think it's an exaggeration
to say that that is the message that
most young men are getting at university
today,
that the only way to be a good man is to
focus all of your energy and attention
on someone else.
Whether it's so,
um,
you know,
on,
on helping women or in helping the
indigenous or whatever it happens to be
that you can't have your own concerns,
you can't have your own needs and you
certainly can't have your own problems
or issues.
Um,
that's the only way you can be a good
person.
So,
yeah.
Um,
I,
it just seemed to me outrageous.
And I kept waiting for other people like
to say something about it.
And I would occasionally talk to others
about it and they'd say,
oh yeah,
they could sort of see.
But they,
you know,
they weren't willing to stick their
necks out in any way.
And um,
so finally I just got to the point where
I thought,
well,
I should do it.
That's a weird position to be in because
I do find so many of the people that
I've talked to that have had similar
evolutions to you,
they don't think of themselves as
particularly brave or particularly like,
oh,
he's the one that wanted to save the
world or anything,
but you get pushed to a point where then
finally you're at that ledge and it's
either they're going to push you over
and you'll never speak again and they'll
disappear or you kind of turn it around
and fight back.
Yeah,
I mean in my case I,
I,
especially I,
it's not that I don't,
I because I do get a rush out of
conflict and that sort of thing,
but for this particular issue,
I don't think I'm very good at it.
I mean,
for one thing it's very difficult to be
on the other side of a social justice
issue because to be on the right side,
the left side,
you have the correct side.
I should say the left side,
it's easy because you hear the arguments
over and over again,
so you just,
you know,
we just have to open your mouth and out.
They all come and,
and usually people are stunned into
embarrassed silence as soon as you start
attacking them with your,
your,
your various claims and your various
charges against them.
But to be able to argue,
I'm really effectively on the other
side.
You not only have to know the,
the,
all the left side arguments,
but then you have to,
you know,
research all,
all these things that you'd been taught
were simply not true or were unthinkable
or were impossible.
and um,
yeah,
it's not,
not my area of expertise.
Certainly,
um,
you know,
my area of expertise is literature,
but um,
and I don't think I'm very good.
Like you have to be good in debate and
you know,
answering people's challenging questions
and I hate all that.
I'm terrible at that.
But,
but,
and so if there were two.
yeah,
so,
and I didn't really,
you know,
and I,
I didn't entirely understand,
um,
what it would be like,
like when I gave my first couple of
talks and uh,
they were protested and they pulled the
fire alarms and there were a lot of
really angry students in the audience.
I really had no idea that it was going
to be like that.
I thought it was just going to.
I was sort of going to talk about
academic feminism in a,
in a sort of bounded way.
And I knew that because I'd studied it
for years,
but I didn't realize I was going to be
asked to answer questions about,
you know,
everything do with the relations between
men and women and rape and all of these
big issues.
So I didn't do a very good job.
I didn't think,
but,
um,
you know,
nobody else is doing it.
And so I want to keep on.
And I started doing my video series
three years ago and um,
and that has given me a lot of
satisfaction actually because as soon as
I started speaking in public,
I got a lot of emails,
an incredible number of emails,
mostly from young men,
some men not that young talking about
their experiences.
And it blew me away that the,
and I know darden's talked about this
too,
but the,
the amount of pain that there is out
there,
um,
the number of young men who just want
to,
they love women in most cases.
They want to have a happy relationship.
they've never intended to hurt or
oppress anyone.
And yet they're told that even without
intending to,
they do just by looking at a young
woman,
you know,
or asking her out on a date.
They're doing some sort of violence and
the pain that that has caused and the
uncertainty and the confusion and the
resentment as well.
It's a,
you know,
in some of these young men have
themselves been abused.
Their parents.
Sometimes their mothers have been
abusive or girlfriends.
And yet they're in,
you know,
they have to hear over and over again
about how it's only men who are ever
abusive.
And that's,
I mean,
it's amazing to me like once you go into
down the rabbit hole or whatever it is,
and you see the,
the,
our culture from the other side,
and every time you turn on the news,
there's yet another story about,
you know,
whatever the terrible problem of cat
calling and how it represents,
you know,
the,
the deep misogyny of north american
culture and what needs to be done about
it and,
you know,
all that kind of thing kind of thing.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's astounding.
So,
so now I sort of feel like I'm with my
video is anyway,
that my,
my role is to at least to say to young
men that you're not crazy.
It,
our culture is,
is actually crazy.
All right,
so let's talk about this crisis in
masculinity.
Uh,
is that,
is that the right way to phrase it?
Do you think these?
Sure.
Yeah,
that's fine.
that'll work.
Okay.
That there do seem to be so many men
who,
as you said,
they don't hate women,
they,
they don't hate themselves,
they don't,
they,
but they're sort of wounded and
confused.
I see these people often at jordan's
shows and I don't even mean that,
that shows her filled with these people.
There's just people that are kind of
confused.
Their roadmap is a little screwed up and
he's kind of helping them get back on
the road.
I don't,
he doesn't even talk about gender that
often or,
or any of that stuff.
For whatever reason,
his broader message of clean up your
room,
get your stuff together,
fix yourself before you fix the world.
That seems to be a message that these
people are hearing this crisis.
Are you able to really figure out how
widespread it is?
I mean,
I know you're getting,
you're getting sort of emails and you're
putting up your video series and all
that,
but like can you really tell like how
much of this as just sort of gone across
culture because it does seem to sort of
be the beginnings of the next culture
war?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
yeah,
it's,
it's hard to say exactly.
I mean,
certainly at the university there has
been a tremendous decline in men
attending net.
Women now dominate in numbers at pretty
well,
you know,
every university,
at least in north America,
and I assume it's true in western europe
as well.
Now,
there might be lots of reasons for that,
but one has to assume that at least a
part of the reason is that men feel that
there isn't a place for them at the
university.
Um,
and it,
the relentless man blaming and shaming
that goes on there has got to have
something to do with that I would think.
Um,
and there are a number of reports
certainly that I've read recently
indicate that in a whole bunch of other
ways,
men are just not doing very well
generally either.
There was a report that came out a few
years ago called I'm a wayward sons.
It came out of mit to economists talking
about how,
um,
in a number of different metrics,
whether it was skills acquisition,
a real wages,
I'm just employment numbers.
Um,
job status.
Men are falling behind women really
shockingly,
and then that's leading into all sorts
of other social problems too.
Men are not getting married because
they're not in a position to be able to
support a family and there are many
other reasons why men are not getting
married as well.
And so Then that means that I'm more and
more women are,
are raising their children outside of
marriage and that often has very bad
impacts for the boys in those single mom
situations.
Um,
they,
they tend to be the ones that are hurt
most by the lack of a father.
And,
and so yeah,
it certainly seems that there's some
pretty widespread problems.
Suicide,
male suicide is something that a lot of
people that I work with are very
concerned about mental illness,
uh,
what they call failure to launch,
meaning just a lot of young men just
feeling that there isn't anything for
them in society.
And so why even try to contribute
anything to it at all.
It does seem to be a pretty widespread
problem from what people like warren
farrell,
who studied the subject for years
certainly.
And of course christina hoff sommers as
well,
or.
Yeah.
What,
what are the tactics that you've seen
work effectively to,
if someone contacts you and you know,
they're,
they're feeling all of the things that
you've discussed or not feeling,
what they're experiencing,
do you have a sorta a groundwork for how
they can kind of get their lives in
order and,
and fight some of this.
It's really just,
you're just making them aware.
Yeah,
I mean I'd be friends with them and,
and uh,
and I,
I tell them that what they're feeling
has a real basis.
I mean that part of the problem is that
they're told that they're their only
problem is a sense of entitlement,
you know,
which is the last thing that's true
about men's experience today.
So part of the thing is that,
I mean,
I think many of the young men that write
to me,
it's not that they necessarily think
they're the biggest victims in the
world.
It's that there is not even a smidgen of
awareness that they would ever have
anything to worry about.
The sense that you know,
everything that they have.
It's because they're so privileged.
I'm
so,
what a weird ways is through that lens.
It's like society,
you should have everything.
You should feel great.
Look,
you've been handed everything,
but then is continually making you feel
like crap,
which is like a completely double edge
sword because you're supposed to feel
great.
You feel like crap.
They're never given you a chance to feel
good because there's nothing you can do
to get yourself out of it.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's.
I mean,
I,
I think it's a,
it is a devastating social problem.
Um,
and again,
yeah,
I don't know the exact extent of the
problem,
but from what people who know and have
studied it more certainly indicating
that it is a growing problem.
And,
and,
um,
you know,
in the circles that,
that I sort of,
um,
pay attention to,
you know,
there's this movement called meg towel,
which I'm know you know about and I'm a
man who are just have decided the
acronym breakdown to men going their own
way.
Yeah.
And,
and I'm not an on,
on meg towels.
Certainly women who are we fighting for,
for,
uh,
for them to think of me pronouncing on
it,
I'm sure,
but,
um,
and there can be different reasons and
in the most,
in the broadest definition,
I think it's just men saying,
look,
I'm going to focus my life around my own
pursuits and I'm not going to focus my
life around a woman.
And these men tend to think that
actually that's a trap that a lot of men
fall into is,
is making everything about a woman.
Um,
and then you can get,
you know,
really can be destroyed if you,
if the woman you happen to focus your
life around is crazy or malevolent in
some way,
she can destroy her man.
Um,
by making a claim of abuse,
he can find that,
um,
the marriage he built,
the home that he built,
the children that he fathered all can be
taken away from him.
His life can be destroyed,
his business can be taken away,
his reputation could be ruined.
You know,
all of those things.
And,
and so there's so much risk to these
young men in these involvements that a
lot of them are just deciding a safer
not to,
not to risk anything,
but I think there's a more general thing
too.
It's just,
um,
anyone it has to do with that sense that
every day in some way,
some of these men are beginning to feel
like their society just doesn't even
like them.
It's not even that they're expendable,
which I think most men who have studied
the situation of men throughout history
would say that's always been the case.
Men have always been,
yeah,
men are the ones that go to war.
Why to,
to protect the women.
So this idea that all of human history
is about male power and privilege and,
and men abusing women.
Um,
you know,
these men and say it's actually the
exact opposite.
Um,
women have always been the ones who are
precious in society,
particularly in western society and know
chivalry and everything else.
Um,
so that was always the situation.
But expandability is one thing.
But to be actually despised by your
years,
your society,
and told that there's nothing good about
you,
that even your sacrifices aren't good
enough and yet you're still supposed to
make the sacrifices.
But they'll never,
you'll never get any,
any kind of public acknowledgement of
that.
Why we say it's bOwing forever.
There is no reclamation here.
It's,
it's a,
it's a perpetual stay there.
Yeah.
You can never purge your toxic
masculinity no matter what you do,
unless you die,
I guess,
you know,
rescuing somebody.
But,
uh,
but even then,
yeah,
I mean,
and then that gets flipped over and then
that's an example of,
you know,
patriarchal,
objectification of women or something.
I mean,
it really is like,
it's,
it's sick when you,
when you listen to.
I mean,
I've read lately so many studies.
One about,
um,
this was by a feminist sociologist and
sociology is really,
I mean,
it's just crazy.
this was a woman who has done work with
the homeless in ontario.
And her whole shtick was about how I'm
even amongst the homeless a certain,
um,
ideas associated with hegemonic
masculinity could still be found in,
in,
she interviewed various homeless men and
the fact that the homeless are
overwhelmingly men right away,
you know,
it shouldn't be for it points to
something.
Doesn't it say something about male
privilege in our society that you,
yeah,
you walk around the streets of ottawa,
you almost never see a homeless woman.
you see a lot of homeless men and a lot
of homeless white men as well as
homeless anyway.
Men.
Um,
anyways,
so she had done thIs work with homeless
men and,
and uh,
and she interviewed them and yeah,
she found that either either they were
lamenting the loss of their hegemonic
masculinity or they were even so trying
to assert their hegemonic masculinity in
various ways.
I mean,
it was just,
it was truly crazy.
It had nothing to do.
And she actually recommended at the end
of the article that program's working
with these men should perhaps,
you know,
help them to whatever renounced their
hegemonic masculinity.
There was another
article that's obviously their number
one.
Yeah,
that's their number one problem.
I mean,
it's just unbelievable.
There was another article I read just
recently saying that the programs to
encourage men to be responsible fathers.
This was,
I think these were american programs.
I think she was studying,
um,
that such programs also reinforce
patriarchal because they reinforce this
idea that um,
you know,
men have an important role to play as
fathers.
And she actually said that this was a
typical reassertion of patriarchal
thinking in that the implicit assumption
was that women that mothers aren't
sufficient for their children.
So I mean she basically outright said
that that children don't need fathers
and fathers have no necessary role In
their children's lives.
So a lot of scientific evidence at that
time.
That's not correct.
Exactly,
yeah.
That it's deeply damaging to children.
Do you sense that there's a movement now
for women and I think you'd probably be
included in this,
but that young women that are looking to
get married and in their,
you know,
late teens,
early twenties,
that they want men back.
So I can only give an anecdotal example
of this,
but I have a lot of single,
straight female friends that have their
lives together,
have jobs,
take care of themselves,
etc.
Etc.
And we have this running joke that I
don't know virtually any straight men
like that.
I know a lot of gay guys that seemingly
have their lives together and that are
doing all of those things and that's
probably.
I don't know if you have any thoughts on
that.
It's sorta kinda decide barb,
it's sort of interesting,
but that they're,
they want there to be men to find and
it's become like a running joke for me.
Like I don't know where they are.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
I think those women are going to have to
start asking why it is that they're not
there.
And some of the,
the reason I would say is precisely that
they're just not,
they're not willing anymore to be there
because it isn't possible.
I mean obviously there are lots of men
who are still willing to take on
responsibility and be the achievers and
all of that.
But I think there has been sort of a
general,
um,
a lot of men are,
are disgusted with the,
the paucity of options that are,
that are offered to them and they feel
that,
um,
you know,
just there,
there are too many risks for them
involved in doing the things that they
might have once wanted to do.
Um,
and I think a lot of men are,
are damaged too from the,
the decades of relentless propaganda,
anti male propaganda.
How do you think this is all connected
to the me too movement?
So I just want to be clear on one thing.
So as we're taping this,
because I'm on tour with Jordan at the
moment,
we are holding this video for a little
bit.
So the moment we're taping this right
now is the cabin our hearings and it
just feels like everything that you've,
uh,
talked about here for the last 45 or so
minutes.
It seems like it's all being unearthed
now publicly in our political arena.
That's why I think this is so much more
of a culture thing than a political
thing directly.
But can you relate all of this to me
too?
Well,
there's so much about me too.
I mean,
I think partly what me to represented
for me anyway,
I'm like so many women have been told
for so many years that the whole history
of our culture is a history of male
privilege.
And so,
but in fact,
you know,
most women,
um,
least I would say lower middle class to
upper middle class women have had lives
in which they have been told from day
one that they really matter.
Certainly that was my experience.
I never,
you know,
I was born in 1964,
so I'm going back to the,
I guess I was the beneficiary of the
second wave feminist movement.
And certainly I always knew that
everybody in my life,
all of the people at my school,
you know,
all the coaches,
the mentors,
the teachers,
they wanted me to do well.
And I think a lot of women have had that
message.
new you can do whatever you want to do
and we encourage you to go,
girl,
you know,
you can be great.
You can be a,
a rocket scientist.
You can do something else,
you know,
and,
and whatever you do,
you'll be supported in it,
but at the same time though,
as an antifeminist now second wave
feminism back then.
Pretty good.
Oh,
well,
that's a whole other.
Oh,
I mean,
it had the seeds of the deep patriot of
men in it.
I mean,
it was the one that started a rape
culture and the history of women was a
history of male sexual violence and the
men kept women in check by,
by sexually abusing them or by
threatening them with sexual abuse.
When you said that you,
that you were born out of that,
that things were okay.
Well,
certainly things were wonderful in the
19 seventies.
I mean,
my argument would be that they would
have been pretty good anyway.
I think,
you know,
I think ever since women got the vote
and men,
we're happy to extend it to them without
any of the responsibilities that men who
had the vote had always had to take on,
such as military service and the
willingness to die for you're defending
your country.
Uh,
I think everything every ever since that
happened,
basically men have shown themselves
pretty open to admitting women into the
professions and encouraging women to,
um,
you know,
to make whatever kind of contribution
they could make to,
to,
uh,
to our culture.
Anyway.
So,
so yeah,
there's a lot of things to talk about
that for sure.
But,
so basically what I would say though is
that women,
while at the same lot,
while being encouraged while feeling
that they are an awful lot of positive
attention and energy are focused on them
at the same time,
they've always been fed this,
this revenge narrative,
you know,
that somehow the past,
it was all terrible for hundreds and
hundreds of years.
They've been abused.
And so,
um,
so we're getting to the point now we're
having been fed that and I really do
think it is an outright lie.
And the problem is to now that all of
history has been sort of rewritten.
And so it's actually very difficult to
find out the reality of history because
we have it filtered through our popular
culture and things we think we know
about.
For instance,
women winning the right to vote and the
fact that there were a whole bunch of
men,
certainly in Canada and great britain
who couldn't vote at the same time the
women were campaigning for the right to
vote.
Almost nobody knows that at all,
which men couldn't vote,
or those poor men.
Um,
there were,
there were property and um,
um,
wage qualifications at the time.
So,
um,
yeah,
there were,
there were certain restrictions.
Many of the men who went and fought in
the first world war,
for instance,
the young men,
they couldn't vote either.
So,
so,
but we have this idea that for centuries
men could vote and basically ran society
and,
and women couldn't.
But in fact,
that's not true.
It's just a very narrow window when most
men could vote and when women couldn't.
But anyway,
uh,
and,
and all sorts of other ways,
we have these ideas that women were the
property of their fathers or their
husbands and that they were abused,
that nobody believed them,
that nobody cared if they were raped.
That's,
that's the thing that's coming out now
is I've heard a number of high profile
female commentators say in just up until
the recent past,
nobody believed a woman if she said
she'd been raped,
so now we're going to believe them.
Now,
even if that were true,
it wouldn't make sense and it wouldn't
be just obviously to suddenly now just
believe every time a woman says that a
man has done something to her and we
we're going to destroy that man's career
or we're going to put them in jail.
Was that the most pervasive part of this
though,
that there's a growing feeling amongst
this crew that in order to make an
omelet,
you're going to have to break certain
thing so that you're going to have.
Because they're quite literally.
I mean,
I see this again from that class of blue
check twitter feminists or whatever,
or reporters or whatever they are.
Yeah.
It's okay if a couple of innocent people
getting.
No,
I've seen that over and over again.
Yeah,
it may be.
It is perfectly okay because of the
centuries and centuries of abuse and
yeah,
that's a crazy idea of retributive
justice.
I'm punishing people as a class,
um,
but I think a lot of people,
a lot of while both women and men who,
who by that narrative are so whipped up,
uh,
in,
in outrage over women's supposedly
suffering over the centuries that
they're quite willing to see some men
suffer.
Now.
I mean,
I read an article,
maybe you saw it too saying that
cavenaugh should not be,
uh,
the denomination should be withdrawn
because,
um,
although maybe we shouldn't put men into
prison just based on a woman's
unsubstantiated and story from 36 years
ago.
But hey,
come on,
you know,
supreme court,
well,
all but five men in the,
you know,
in the country,
don't get to do that.
so big deal,
you know,
it's not.
And then that's certainly been the
attitude about the,
the um,
the tribunals that have been put in
place in american universities to,
you know,
people would say,
well,
there's no like there,
there are no standards of justice here.
There's no opportunity to cross examine
witnesses.
You're not allowed to have a lawyer.
Sometimes the men weren't even allowed
to know what the charges against them
were and they'd always come out and say,
well,
but they're not going to be put in
prison.
They're just going to be expelled from
universities as a pretty minor.
Right.
Well,
that's why I think this topic is so
interesting because I'm not
particularly.
I don't particularly care about feminism
or any of these isms.
One word there.
I want everyone to be treated equally,
or at least I want.
I want the laws of the nation to treat
everyone equally and then it's on you to
figure out the rest and sometimes there
are bad people and you have to go out
and do it yourself and figure it out.
Okay,
but what now I see happening and now I
see why this,
this sort of crazed feminism piece is so
directly related to free speech or the
issues I really care about is the way
that we're.
This is connected to due process.
Now this is connected to.
Yeah,
we're gonna break a couple of eggs and
we're actually going,
we're going to probably jail people.
We're going to probably get people fired
and all of these things that you've put
out there.
So I do see these,
these ties to much greater issues and
this in a weird way,
this is why a lot of people,
I think peter goes into,
I've had on this show,
has talked about how the gender studies
really is ground zero for this entire
movement.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
And I've seen this.
I mean this has been going on in Canada
for a number of years and it does.
And gender studies is the ground zero I
think.
and part of it is this,
this,
uh,
this idEa that the,
you know,
things like the presumption of innocence
that those really are structures
designed,
especially in the cases of,
you know,
sexual assault law,
that that's designed to protect bad men.
And therefore,
and I've,
so I've read all sorts of articles by,
by law students saying,
okay,
we know what we know,
what rape trials look like when
presumption of innocence is the,
is the default or is the standard,
what would they look like if we started
by believing and,
and that whole notion of believing women
as the,
as the fundamental legal standard.
It's terrifying.
What do you think are the best steps to,
to help people that are waking up?
So you talked about how the,
the,
you know,
you get all these emails from men and
you can hopefully listen to them and
that sort of thing.
But if they're there because they're out
there,
they're watching this right now.
Well,
I'm not hopeful.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't have the answers.
I really don't.
I think that we're,
we're really in a mess right now.
Um,
if,
if I wanted to say something really
inflammatory,
I,
what I would say is that when I was a
phd student,
I used to read newspapers from the 18
seventies,
eighties,
and eighties,
nineties because that was my period that
I was working in.
And I wanted to see what kinds of
conversations were going on and I did a
feminist phd,
I was interested in,
in female journalists of the 18 eighties
and nineties.
And there is no,
there Were all sorts of debates about
gender relations as we would call it now
going on then.
And one of them was a question of
women's political role,
how,
you know,
to what extent should women be
politically involved.
And really the late 19th century was a
time when,
because of advances in,
in,
um,
a domestic equipment and because of some
rudimentary birth control measures,
when more women were able to make a
contribution at the public level in a
way they'd never really been able to
unless I had been single.
Um,
but,
um,
so there were all these debates and know
most men were pretty enthusiastic about
the idea of women becoming more publicly
involved.
And there was very much a sense that
women would.
Women brought a certain kind of morality
that women were superior morally than
men.
And we still see that now.
I think the whole idea that women don't
lie about things,
you know,
about rape or,
and various other things that women can
end war.
Women can negotiate better than men.
All that,
you know,
that all ties in.
Yeah,
well that's true.
But you know,
it's still the idea that women have
something in them that uh,
you know,
is,
is perhaps morally superior or gives
them a certain qualities that men don't
have still there.
So it was very much that.
And um,
but the,
the,
the anti feminist position at the time
said it.
It's dangerous.
Women are too emotional.
Women are less rational than men.
Women can take pr,
they personalize everything so they're
not able to sort of separate themselves
and uh,
you know,
make decisions that in an objective,
unbiased manner and you have that kind
of thing and you know,
they,
this was related to women's biology and
various things.
And I remember I used to laugh and think
how ridiculous that was.
And yet I have to say that over the last
10 years as I have seen,
I mean because me to which claims it's
this new conversation.
It isn't really new,
I mean this has been going on at least
since anita hill and clarence thomas and
you know,
certainly throughout the 19 nineties
following anita hill's charges against
thomas.
There was a lot of discussion about
sexual harassment in the workplace and
what we're going to do about it.
A lot of legislation brought in a lot of
innocent men,
you know,
disciplined or fired from their jobs as
a result of various claims women made
that they'd been made to feel
uncomfortable or you know,
whatever it happened to be.
And so This has been going on for a long
time.
I think.
And I have to say that it makes me
wonder sometimes whether those
antifeminist from the late 19th century
were right.
That what is it about this mass movement
so angry,
this movement of vengeance that is
starting to make these completely
irrational claims about how we should
proceed,
who we should believe,
why,
why it doesn't matter that we suspend
basic principles of presumption of
innocence and due process.
How can it be?
This is actually being taken seriously
in our public culture.
And I mean,
I don't know,
but I do have to wonder whether the
presence of women isn't having some kind
of really deleterious effect on our
public conversations about these things.
That was only if you wanted to end on an
inflammatory.
Yeah.
I really thoroughly enjoyed this.
I mean,
it's,
it's such an interesting topic because
it hits on so many of the things that I,
that I care about.
I suspect we will do this again.
Thank You very much.
Thanks for coming in and for more on
jadis,
you can follow her on twitter at jenis
fee.
Amigo.